people think you're doing something to
shock them and people think when i'm on
the radio
that i'm trying to shock them that's
what they think my goal is you are
i mean what you certainly have in the
past but do you believe that you're
shocking
i think that thinking for yourself and
having a strong opinion
and going against the grain
is shocking to most people certainly in
my business but are you shocked when
people are shocked by you aren't you
going out there just to entertain them
you want to make people feel good you
want to
sing a song you want to dance you want
to entertain them and yet
they're being shocked by you i'm shocked
that anyone can be shocked by anything i
say but we live in a very puritanical
country
you do understand that killing is okay
but
when i did like a virgin when i
performed it live for the first time
actually my shoe fell off on stage
i'd come down the wedding cake and my
shoe fell off i was like oh [ __ ] i can't
dance in one shoe can i say [ __ ] on
sure yeah i was like how am i gonna play
this out so i just dove for it on the
ground and when i dove for it my dress
went up and my butt was showing
everyone's showing their butt now but
back then nobody saw anyone's butt and i
didn't know my skirt was up
so i proceeded to sing the song laying
down on the ground i was just
making the best of a situation which is
what i do like when i got yanked off the
stage by my cape the other day
when i'm hardwired to just keep going
after i got off stage during that
performance my manager was
white as a ghost and he looked at me
said do you know what you just did and i
said
yeah i sang a song and i lost my shoe on
stage and he's like
no your butt was showing for the entire
song
your career is over and did you believe
him how do you
know i felt really bad but i didn't do
it on purpose right
but there's a panic set in i'm going to
lose everything i'm trying so hard here
i didn't mean to be
controversial no i'm not like that i
wasn't that apologetic
i was just like [ __ ] it i made a mistake
you don't go somewhere and cry and say i
just lost my career
no see i was just terrified all the time
because i was told i was going to lose
my career i think that
when that happens to you year after year
decade after decade at this point you
just it's
it's just noise at this point it's noise
people just like to give me [ __ ]